todo listo aquí en Suiza concretamente
en la ciudad alpina de davos para
recibir a los más de 2700 asistentes
este año al Foro económico mundial la
cita anual de líderes en la que se
analiza los principales temas de la
economía y este año estará centrado en
la cooperación en un mundo fragmentado
que va desde la desaceleración económica
y el fantasma de la recesión hasta la
crisis ambiental pasando Desde luego por
las consecuencias de la crisis en
Ucrania de la guerra en Ucrania el
horario vuelve entonces este año al
invierno después de que el año pasado
hubiera tenido que ser
aplazado para el verano teniendo en
cuenta que en enero del año pasado pues
había la variante o micron estaba
amenazando fuertemente a la economía
europea entre los asistentes brillarán
por su ausencia Los dos presidentes de
las principales economías del mundo
hablamos de Joe biden de Estados Unidos
de China que no harán presencia en este
foro económico que inicia el próximo
lunes y va hasta el viernes quien si va
a entrar será Úrsula wonderlay en la
presidenta de la comisión Europea y
varios presidentes también
latinoamericanos como este evento no
está exento de polémica hablamos
entonces de que uno de los principales
medios de comunicación de acá hablamos
del periódico
en su editorial de hoy ha dicho que el
foro no es la plataforma adecuada para
cambiar el mundo y si deja una gran
huella de carbono ya que uno de cada 10
líderes se desplaza hasta aquí en su Jet
privado algo de lo que también se ha
sumado la organización greenpeace